Professor John Rogers:
"Lycidas" is
probably the most difficult poem
that we'll be reading all
semester.
But, as I mentioned briefly in
the last class,
the notorious difficulties
attending this poem seem to have
very little to do with Milton's
grief over the death of Edward
King,
which may well not have been
all that troubled or
complicated.
We have no evidence,
and I mentioned this before,
that there was a particularly
close relation between these two
young men.The difficulty of
the poem lies to a great degree,
I think, in something that Dr.
Johnson had noted in his attack
or in his criticism on "Lycidas"
that I mentioned on Monday.
Its difficulty lies in Milton's
tendency in this poem to seek
out what Dr.
Johnson wonderfully calls
remote allusions.
This is by far the most learned
and the most demanding lyric
poem that Milton writes.
It's a poem deeply invested in
the tradition of pastoral
poetry, pastoral poetry from
Theocritus and Virgil onward.
It's a poem deeply invested,
in fact, in the entire Western
tradition of poetry in general.
Finally, I think it can be said
that it's a poem whose deepest
investment is actually in
Milton's mastery over the entire
Western tradition of literature.
Milton -- this will be the
working assumption that I bring
to my reading of this poem --
Milton sets out to prove
something in "Lycidas,"
and the most important
thing that he proves is his
control over the learning that
he has accumulated.Now I
spoke last time about the
familiar sense of hesitation,
that apology with which Milton
had opened the elegy.
We hear in the 1637
"Lycidas" those same
cries of unripeness and
under-preparation that we had
heard in the 1631 sonnet,
"How Soon Hath Time,
the Subtle Thief of Youth."
When Milton opens "Lycidas"
with that phrase,
"Yet once more," one of the
things that he's telling the
reader is that yet once more
he'll be making the same
argument for unreadiness;
the same argument for nervous
anticipation that he'd made a
number of times before.
And so as a way of
understanding what at this point
is really the sheer
repetitiveness of this
disclaimer, I want to propose a
metaphor.
I propose that we think of
Milton at the opening of
"Lycidas" as being stuck,
stuck at a particular point in
the imagined,
the projected or fantasized,
trajectory of his career.
I'm using the word "stuck," of
course, because the Lady had
been stuck so famously and so
prominently in
Comus.You may
remember that I had suggested in
the lecture on the Nativity
Ode that Milton may have
thought of his career as if it
were something like a race.
I think here that the
particular image of a career as
a race still holds but with a
little bit of a difference.
What seems so obvious,
at least to me here in reading
"Lycidas," is that
at this point in 1637 there's a
stumbling block or a hurdle that
Milton in his race simply can't
get over.
Now the surest sign of a hurdle
is one of those pointed literary
allusions that Milton makes in
"Lycidas,"
one of those remote
allusions that Johnson had
complained about.
It's an allusion that has
everything to do with Milton's
own sense of his unreadiness,
and I'm thinking of that.
Oh, it's just -- it's
wonderful, that strange moment
that happens fairly early on in
the poem.
This is line seventy-six.
In the Hughes edition,
it's page 122.
It's that moment in which
Phoebus Apollo makes a sudden
and unexpected appearance.
Now not only does Phoebus
Apollo make a sudden appearance,
but he seems actually to
interrupt the speaker of the
poem in order to correct
him.Let's remind ourselves
what's been happening.
Milton has just been lamenting
the fact that the laborious days
of the poet might not result in
a sudden blaze of fame.
What good is it -- you'll
remember -- what good is it,
Milton asks,
"to tend the homely slighted
shepherd's trade";
that's, of course,
the vocation of poetry if that
shepherd-poet is just going to
be struck down in his prime as
Edward King had been?
You'll remember that Milton had
complained that "the thin-spun
life" could be so easily slit --
but look at line seventy-six:
"'But not the praise,'
/ Phoebus repli'd,
and touch'd my trembling ears."
Okay.
[laughs] What's happened?
Phoebus Apollo,
the god of the sun and,
not unimportant,
also the god of poetry --
Phoebus Apollo bursts in to the
text and corrects the poet,
corrects the poet's youthful
interest in earthly fame:
"'Fame is no plant that grows
on mortal soil.'"
True fame exists only in heaven.
The only reputation that
matters is the praise you
ultimately receive from God or "
all-judging Jove;
/ as he pronounces lastly on
each deed."
And as in all of these early
lyrics, Jove conventionally
throughout the Renaissance is
used as a name within these
classical fictions to signify
the Christian God.Now this
moment is striking in part
because we had no idea -- how
could we possibly have had an
idea?
-- that Phoebus Apollo was
actually eavesdropping on the
poet's discourse.
I think we're taken aback here.
We're taken aback by the rude
interruption in the otherwise
seamless flow of the poet's
lament.
This moment is also striking
because Milton has lifted this
entire scene of this
interruption from somewhere
else.
He has taken it from one of the
pastoral poems of Virgil.
The image of a poet interrupted
and chided by the god of poetry
comes straight out of the
opening of Virgil's Sixth
Eclogue.
Virgil had written a poem in
the Sixth Eclogue that had
touched Milton,
and it had touched Milton,
I think, because it begins with
Virgil's own brooding meditation
on the course of his poetic
career.
Now we all know what Virgil's
poetic career would go on to
look like.
Virgil would go on to be a
great epic poet but not until
after he had written these
pastoral eclogues and then after
that,
after he had written the
georgic poems,
only then does he write finally
the great epic poem The
Aeneid.Now in Virgil's
early poem,
the Sixth Eclogue,
the speaker explains that the
writing of pastoral poetry is
the stuff that young poets do.
Poets begin their careers with
easy pastoral poems,
but Virgil's speaker says that
he is more ambitious now.
He's starting to champ at the
bit.
He's ready to write an epic
poem on much more important
subjects than shepherds and
shepherdesses.
He wants to write about kings
and wars.
As soon as he has expressed
this epic ambition -- Virgil
explains that as soon as he's
expressed this Phoebus Apollo,
the god of poetry,
stepped in and chided him.
So this is Virgil:
"When I was fain to sing of
kings and battles,
the Cynthian god" -- that's
Phoebus Apollo -- "plucked my
ear and warned me."
Apollo warns Virgil that a
pastoral poet simply shouldn't
overstep his bounds.
This is Virgil:
"He should sing thin [little,
fine]- spun lays and he should
be content feeding his fat
sheep."
The god told Virgil that he
wasn't ready yet for the manly,
the adult, and the public
world,
the important world,
of epic poetry.All of this
anxiety, and when you think of
it,
all of this shame as well as
the shame of ambition -- all of
this gets packed into this
allusion to Virgil that Milton
brings to this very disturbing
moment in "Lycidas."
It's important,
I think, that this Virgilian
scene with Apollo appears so
early in Milton's "Lycidas."
Milton's "Lycidas"
doesn't end up all soaked in
this unhealthy brew of --
neurotic brew of anxiety and
shame and naked ambition.
I think it's one of our jobs
here to figure out why that's
the case.
Why doesn't -- this is one way
of putting the question -- why
doesn't Apollo harass or bother
Milton at the end of
"Lycidas" in the same way
that he harasses Milton at the
poem's beginning?
Now I think you may be
rather happy to hear that this
is the last time -- I'm pretty
sure that this is the last time
-- that we will have to discuss,
at least at any length,
Milton's worries about his
unreadiness and his
un-preparation.
It's safe to say that
"Lycidas" is one of the
last poetic works of Milton's
that's really consumed with his
problem,
the problem of fruitless
anticipation.
In some ways I think that
that's because the poem
"Lycidas" seems in some ways to
solve the problem of Milton's
waiting,
this problem that he has of
needing to wait.
And so one of the things that
needs to be explored here is why
this poem is the last poem that
Milton is not prepared to write.
What does Milton do -- this is
what I see as our project,
our interpretive project,
as we approach this poem --
what does Milton do to get
himself unstuck from this seat
of anxious anticipation?
That's the project.So we
looked last time at the oddity,
the peculiarity,
of Milton's choice of genre
here, the pastoral genre.
Milton was the only Cambridge
poet to honor Edward King in
that memorial anthology by
writing a poem in the pastoral
mode.
A pastoral, of course,
features shepherds and
shepherdesses as its most
distinguishing characteristic.
The word pastoral comes
from the Latin pastor,
which literally means
"shepherd,"
and Milton knew perfectly well
how artificial his use of the
pastoral mode of poetry would
seem as well as how out of
fashion,
how completely outdated,
it would seem.
One of the motives for his
selection of this genre,
the pastoral genre,
is the tradition -- and it's a
tradition that goes all the way
back to Theocritus and Virgil --
that associates shepherds with
poets.
This has always been a part of
the pastoral genre.
To speak of shepherds and
shepherding in a pastoral poem
seems almost invariably to be a
strategy or a way to speak of
poets and their craft of poetry.
This is a kind of literary
self-consciousness that we're
all familiar with.But
there's another meaning given to
shepherds as well.
After the long sway of
Theocritus' and Virgil's
pastorals, of course
Christianity entered the scene,
a new dispensation;
and Christianity began to load
this pastoral literary tradition
with its own set of
associations.
Shepherds came to represent not
only poets.
They came to stand for
ministers, they came to signify
allegorically ministers as well.
So priests, ministers or
pastors -- we still call them
pastors -- had long been
referred to as shepherds.
They are leaders of their
flocks.
And so it seemed a natural move
for early Christian writers to
use this existing pastoral form
when they wanted to speak on
subject of priests or ministers
or affairs of the
church.Milton is essentially
inheriting both of these
traditions,
both of these sets of
associations with pastoral
poetry.
When we consider the particular
circumstances that occasioned
the poem "Lycidas," we
can see why Milton,
I think, chose this pastoral
form.
Edward King,
the young man,
the elegized deceased,
was a minor poet on his way to
begin his career as a minister,
and the figure of the shepherd,
the pastor, fuses into one
person or into one figurative
entity both of these callings:
the vocation of the poet and
the vocation of the minister.
We've looked before at Milton's
Reason of Church
Government.
That's the political treatise
written in 1642.
We've seen Milton's account
there of how he had attempted to
reconcile, on the one hand,
his obligation to become a
minister and his desire,
on the other hand,
to become a poet.I want to
back up now because I think it's
important to fill in a little
bit of the historical context
behind that long but important
prose treatise.
It's not irrelevant to our
understanding of "Lycidas."
The subject of The
Reason of Church Government
is Milton's feelings about
the hierarchical structure of
the Church of the England.
In the early years of the
English Revolution,
one of the hottest flash points
of political contention was the
degree of appropriate state
involvement in the church.
As with almost all of the
issues of contemporary and
political struggle in the
seventeenth century,
Milton's own views really pull
decidedly to the left,
to the progressive end of the
political spectrum.
Beginning in the late 1630s at
the moment in which "Lycidas"
is being written,
Milton is becoming increasingly
radical.
We can think of it -- this is
an anachronistic term -- but
increasingly leftist,
and he's becoming one of those
figures that we can now identify
with this label of
"Puritan."Puritans at this
moment in English history were
placing,
when thinking about how things
should work at church,
more and more emphasis on the
sermon,
the institution of the sermon.
The act of preaching sermons
for Puritans was becoming more
important, actually,
than following the ceremonial
rituals of the Church of
England.
So in the years just before
1637, the English court under
James I and then later under
Charles I -- the English crown
had been cracking down on the
delivery of Puritan sermons in
the church.
In 1633, William Laud had been
appointed the Archbishop of
Canterbury, and he had been
granted an extraordinary set of
arbitrary powers of suppression,
actually, by the monarch.
Laud took his mission as
the head of the Church of
England to be the squelching of
this Puritan opposition.
The most outrageous action in
Laud's crackdown was his move to
ban -- his attempt to ban
preaching in churches.
So under Archbishop Laud,
only the official liturgy could
be recited in church.
As you can imagine,
this was controversial.
A struggle breaks out in the
church, and Milton naturally
takes the Puritan position in
favor of preaching.
The church shouldn't be under
the control of the bishops --
this is Milton's argument -- or
prelates,
a common seventeenth-century
word for bishops,
but the church should be led by
preachers: men who were chosen
by their congregations to
preach.
Eventually this is where we get
the notion of
congregationalism.So given
all of the controversies raging
around the question of the
proper government of the church,
and Milton is deeply invested
in these matters,
Milton feels obliged to do
something.
This is one of the reasons that
he writes The Reason
of Church Government,
this intense sense of
obligation that he feels.
He feels duty-bound to
participate materially in this
political controversy rather
than merely remaining in his
studious retirement,
however pleasant that is,
at his father's house.
Were Milton not to fight in
some way to defend what he takes
to be the true church,
he would simply not be
investing those talents that God
had given him.
This is the Miltonic logic that
we're familiar with.So this
is the situation that Milton
finds himself in as he's writing
"Lycidas." He's under the
greatest pressure of his life to
do something with his talent.
He wants of course -- at least
we assume that he still wants to
be a poet.
At the same time,
he fears that being a poet
means -- and this is a fear that
literate young men and women
have to this very day -- to be a
poet means in some way not to be
acting responsibly or
politically.
So Milton explains in The
Reason of Church Government --
he tries to mend this breach
and so he argues in this
treatise that "Poetry has" --
and I'm quoting him here --
"Poetry has a power beside the
office of the pulpit."
Milton even claims that poetry
is equal to preaching in its
ability to move people,
to get them to do something,
to make things happen in the
world.
Of course,
this is a lot of pressure to
put on poetry and especially a
lot of pressure to put on a
pastoral elegy that's ostensibly
about shepherds and sheep;
but it is the duty of this poem
"Lycidas" to show that
poetry can exert a power beside
the office of the pulpit,
that it can do the same kind of
work that a preacher is able to
accomplish behind the pulpit.
Milton has to develop a poetic
voice that can actually combine
those two vocations,
the two offices,
the office of poetry and the
office of ministry.
If we want to think of it in
the more familiar domestic
context, Milton has to begin a
career that could please both
himself and his father.Now
last time I mentioned the
dramatic structure of this poem.
You'll remember it features a
succession of four mourners,
and we could think of each of
these mourners providing Milton
with an opportunity to try out a
different voice.
One of the voices utterly mops
the floor [laughs]
with all of the others.
Certainly, it stands far
outside the generally pastoral
framework of the poem.
The most striking,
the most powerful,
of all of the mourning voices
here is that of Saint Peter.
This is the figure that Milton
refers to in line 109 as the
Pilot of the Galilean
Lake.Now what's Saint Peter
doing in this poem?
The very mention of Saint Peter
naturally violates the
classical, pastoral fiction of
the poem.
Up to this point,
the Christian God has been
referred to as Jove.
That's how the poem works since
it's within the pagan world,
the pagan fictional world of
the classical pastoral that this
Christian poem is set.
To speak both of Jove and of
Christ is obviously in some ways
to mix your metaphors and the
effect can only be disorienting.
The character of Peter brought
directly out of the New
Testament is really slicing
through the poem's fictive
veneer.
Peter cuts a figure so daunting
and so terrifying that we're
almost led to forget that the
poem we're reading is a pastoral
elegy at all,
so unbelievable is Peter's
discourse.
Okay, line 109:
Last came,
and last did go, The Pilot
of the Galilean Lake.
Two massy Keys he bore of
metals twain (The Golden
opes, the Iron shuts amain).
He shook his Mitred locks,
and stern bespake…
Now this is important to Milton.
This is decidedly the last of
all the funeral mourners,
and Peter provides Milton's
poem with an important element
of finality, of closure.
Peter wields the keys of the
kingdom of heaven and can open
and shut the doors of personal
salvation,
just as he can open and shut
the doors of the church.
That's his function.
It's the sentiments that Peter
utters that, I think,
most powerfully grab us,
and they grab us because they
are so angry -- they're so
violent in their anger.
As the head of the true church,
Peter's voicing here his
disgust that the virtuous Edward
King, soon to become a minister,
had been lost at sea.
Think of the logic of what
Peter's saying here.
He would gladly have traded
dozens -- he would have traded
dozens of corrupt Anglican
ministers for the simple and
honest King.
Look at line 113.
This is where Peter is
addressing Edward King himself:
How well could I have
spared for thee,
young swain, Enough of such
as for their bellies' sake,
Creep and intrude and
climb into the fold?
The corrupt clergy of today,
under the malign influence of
the horrible Archbishop Laud,
are interested only in
satisfying their own greed.
In order to fill their own
bellies, so greedy are they,
they intruded into the church's
fold and devour for themselves
-- this is how the allegory
works -- devour for themselves
the nourishment that of course
they should be sharing with
their flock.But this wish
that [laughs]
other shepherds had died and
not Edward King is so strange.
You can't deny it.
There is something here of a
kind of indecorous tone of
malice, that the priests and the
prelates of the church are so
corrupt according to Saint Peter
that we're led to assume almost
-- not that this is a direct
charge but implicitly,
I think, this is what Peter is
conveying -- it's almost as if
they're responsible for Edward
King's death;
as if by creeping into the
church's fold,
somehow they've managed to push
poor Edward King out of the
fold.
It's a hint at the malevolent
agency of these priests,
and it should point us to the
true outrageousness of this
speech, maybe its irrationality.
We already know that Edward
King -- of course he wasn't
killed by the prelates of the
Church of England!
He was drowned and the drowning
was an accident.
The poem never questions that,
and it's ridiculous to lay his
death at the church's door.
The poem nonetheless harbors
this wonderfully primitive and
irrational accusation.
There's a lapse in logic here,
and this lapse should focus our
interest all the more on the
urgency that we feel in Saint
Peter's speech.
This isn't just a speech.
This is a vitriolic tirade,
and it gets ugly.
Milton needs to get ugly here.
He needs to voice this tirade,
and he needs to write this
politically motivated
harangue.As you'll see it
starts to pick up more and more
enemies as it moves along.
Look at line 119:
Blind mouths!
that scarce themselves know how
to hold A Sheep-hook,
or have learn'd aught else the
least That to the faithful
Herdman's art belongs!"
The faithful herdman's art in
"Lycidas" is a double one.
It's the Christian art of
ministering to a religious
flock, it's that of the pastor,
and it's the more classical art
of poetry.
The men against whom Saint
Peter is really spitting his
venom are bad pastors in every
sense of the word.
They're corrupt not only as
ministers but they are also
corrupt as poets.
They're bad poets.
Look at line 123.
These are such great lines:
"And when they list,
their lean and flashy songs /
grate on their scrannel Pipes of
wretched straw."
I have to read these lines
again: "And when they list,
their lean and flashy songs /
grate on their scrannel Pipes of
wretched straw."
It seems to be the case that
Milton's made this word up,
this wonderful word
scrannel.
It seems to mean something like
"scrawny."
At least that's what the OED
tells us;
the only example that they can
find of the word scrannel
is in Milton's
"Lycidas."This last line
that I've read seems itself to
have been grated on a scrannel
pipe.
It's such an unpleasant line.
It's always worth asking
yourself what a line of poetry
that is as aggressively
unpleasant as this one is doing
in a poem.
The sheer cacophony of the
clustered consonants in this
line sets off -- or has the
potential to set off -- a
powerful cluster of feelings.
The anger here is directed
against the superficial,
the flashy, liturgies read by
the Laudian priests,
but I think it's also being
directed at the lean and flashy
songs that are being written by
Milton's poetic contemporaries,
his rival poets.
Saint Peter has arrived from
heaven into this poem to express
perhaps for the first time the
envy and the anger that Milton
seems successfully to have
suppressed up to this point:
envy and anger not only at the
state of the Church of England
in the late 1630s but also the
state of poetry in England at
this time.So Saint Peter
concludes with -- it goes on,
and he concludes with a couplet
that is as terrifying in its
threat of finality as it is for
me utterly baffling in its
significance.
Look at the last two lines:
"But that two-handed engine at
the door / stands ready to smite
once, and smite no more."
Now we will never know,
and don't let anyone ever
suggest to you that you will
ever know,
what Milton could possibly mean
by this deliberately perplexing
image of the two-handed engine
at the door.
If you ever want to take a look
at -- and I urge you to --
The Variorum Commentary on
the Poems of John Milton in
the CCL collection,
you should peruse it.
It's a massive,
wonderful multi-volume work
that catalogs all of the
critical commentary on Milton's
shorter poems up until some
point in the ‘70s.
There are no less than twenty
pages devoted to the critical
debate on these two lines:
what the hell Saint Peter's
two-handed engine is,
what it looks like,
what it [laughs]
does, what -- and everything
about it.
We have no idea what this
menacing contraption actually is
supposed to look like or what
it's actually intended to
signify,
but we can know,
I think, with some certainty
that it's not scrannel.
Size matters here;
and this -- the two-handed
engine -- is big,
and it works,
and it's able to put an
apocalyptic end to all
corruption and in fact it's able
to put something like an
apocalyptic end to all life.
It stands ready to smite once
and smite no more.Now we
began this poem with the sense
of the dreary repetitiveness in
that opening phrase,
"Yet once more," but here very
close to the poem's end we have
a vision of an end to all those
fruitless exercises of
repetition.
Milton corrects -- it's as if
he's correcting the sense of
monotony with which he had begun
the poem,
and he corrects that sense of
monotony by rewriting that
initial phrase.
Whatever the two-handed engine
is, it will smite once and smite
no more.
It's incapable of repeating
itself.Now,
I think there's a deliberate
confusion here about these lines
because their precise historical
significance isn't what's most
significant.
What may be most important here
is the mere fact that Milton is
expressing these political
convictions at all.
The speech of Saint Peter
seems, I think,
in a lot of ways to be a lot
more like a fire and brimstone
sermon than it is a passage in a
pastoral poem.
The strangely sermonic tone
that this speech assumes is,
I think, exactly the point.
Milton is able in this speech
to combine, I think,
for the first time the two
associations borne by that Latin
word pastor.
So in this guise with the mask
of Saint Peter on he's --
Milton's -- able to be both poet
and minister.
He's investing his rhetorical
talent in an art that's actually
doing something.
It's capable of moving people
to action, or so Milton may have
believed.
It's as if Milton is saying,
"Look at me.
I may be a poet.
I may actually -- I'm simply
writing a pastoral poem,
but I'm actually doing
something in the world.
I'm ministering to a flock.
I'm preaching just as my father
and just as all of my Cambridge
classmates had advised me to
do."
This outburst allows Milton to
solve what may have seemed up to
this point an insoluble
conflict: the insoluble conflict
between the two meanings of the
word vocation that we've
been exploring.
So this passage is extreme and
Milton's poem,
wonderfully,
is perfectly able to identify
it as such.Look what happens
next.
After the passage is over,
Milton addresses Alpheus,
a river god -- the god who was
noted for plunging the course of
his river underground in order
to chase the nymph Arethuse who
had been turned into a fountain.
Alpheus is also the god of
erotic pastoral poetry,
it turns out,
and this god is literally gone
underground during the
terrifying appearance of Saint
Peter.
It's here although we didn't
know the god was there.
[laughs]
This is another familiar and
strange feature of this poem.
We didn't know the god was
there, and we didn't know he was
underground until Milton tells
us that he's coming up now.
It's here, once that speech is
over, that Milton can bid
Alpheus return,
line 132: "Return,
Alpheus, the dread voice is
past / that shrunk thy
streams…"The dread
voice of the angry sermonic
Milton,
the ministerial Milton,
has passed.
It has passed and it is past.
It's part of the past.
And it's at this point,
and I think it's,
importantly,
not before this point,
that Milton's able to throw
himself fully into that
eroticized conjecture,
that catalog of all the flowers
that was to be thrown onto the
hearse bearing Lycidas' body
that we looked at last time.
I mentioned in the last lecture
that the famous flower passage
here of course is -- this is
pure fantasy.
Lycidas' body is nowhere to be
found, and there's nothing,
of course, to throw the flowers
on;
but I think we can see now a
way in which Milton has
permitted himself the fantasy of
this -- of a recovered body or,
as he says, this is line 153,
he has allowed his "frail
thoughts to dally with false
surmise."
Milton can allow himself a
literary indulgence in the rich
sensuality of this passage
because he has mastered the
dread voice,
he has mastered the fatherly
sternness of Saint Peter.
It's as if Milton -- we can
think of Milton as having paid
his dues.
He's accomplished his
ministerial duty as a zealous
and a politically oriented poet,
and now he's earned the right
to dally with false surmise.
He's earned the right to treat
himself to this absolutely
lovely -- what must have been an
extraordinary amount of fun to
write -- lovely catalog of
flowers.
It's almost as if the flower
passage is Milton's reward for
having written the Saint Peter
passage.
And I'm trying to suggest that
Milton's composition of this
poem is actually doing something
for him,
that it gets him somewhere,
and that it's functional in a
genuine sense.It's our
obligation now to look at the
poem's conclusion.
Where does "Lycidas" lead
Milton?
Look at line 183.
Milton imagines Lycidas in
heaven now.
It's a Christian poem.
Then it imagines Lycidas a
little differently as the
genius loci,
the natural classical spirit of
the place,
the genius loci of the
Irish Sea.
This is line 183:
Henceforth thou art the
Genius of the shore, In thy
large recompense,
and shalt be good To all
that wander in that perilous
flood.
[Period.]
Thus sang the uncouth
Swain to th'Oaks and rills,
While the still morn went out
with Sandals gray;
He touch't the tender stops of
various Quills, With eager
thought warbling his Doric
lay: And now the Sun had
stretch't out all the hills,
And now was dropt into the
Western bay;
At last he rose,
and twitch't his Mantle
blue: Tomorrow to fresh
Woods, and Pastures new.
I want to draw your attention
to line 186.
This is the line that begins
the poem's final verse paragraph
and it has to be one of the most
amazing moments in all of
English literature.
"Thus sang" -- these five
words: "Thus sang the uncouth
swain."
Okay.
What are we being told here?
This poem, this entire poem
before this point hasn't been
sung by John Milton at all.
We naturally thought that it
was the poet John Milton who was
speaking the first 185 lines of
the poem.
We naturally assumed that it
was Milton himself who was
describing his college
friendship with "Lycidas"'
Edward King.
We naturally assumed that the
poet was speaking,
even behind the pastoral mask,
because we'd been given no idea
whatsoever of any alternative to
the poet's responsibility for
all of these words being uttered
over the course of this
admittedly very long poem;
but with little ado [laughs]
this just happens.
Milton suddenly and
unexpectedly shatters all of our
assumptions.
He tells us that everything
that we've read up to this point
that has been spoken by a
third-person narrator.
We didn't know this.
It has been spoken by the
uncouth swain,
a rustic shepherd.
Everything that we had thought
that Milton was telling us in
the lyric present -- telling us
directly,
now -- suddenly gets shoved
back into the narrative past:
"thus sang the uncouth swain."
The past tense is important
there.
This is the first moment,
right now, "thus sang the
uncouth swain."
This is the first moment that
the poet John Milton is actually
speaking in his own voice,
and he's speaking directly to
us.
We don't actually hear John
Milton until we hear this line:
"Thus sang the uncouth
swain."Well,
we should be shocked,
and I think beyond that we have
every right to feel a little bit
betrayed,
because Milton quite simply has
-- and he's doing this
deliberately -- he has just
violated an important law.
We could think of it as the
contractual relation that a
writer makes with his reader.
When there's a speaker of a
poem who is not to be confused
with the poet himself,
there is typically a framing
device.
You can easily imagine Milton
employing a framing device here.
He could have begun
"Lycidas" with this,
with something like a
description of the uncouth
swain: "Oh,
let me tell you about this
uncouth swain."
Then he could tell us the
mournful lay that the uncouth
swain sang, and then he could
say, "Thus sang the uncouth
swain."
There would be an opening
framing device and then,
of course, an end frame device.
But Milton's framing device
[laughs]
in "Lycidas" only frames the
end of the poem.
It's asymmetrical.I think
we're fully entitled to ask why:
why Milton waits for the last
eight lines of his poem to tell
us that there's a difference,
that there's a difference
between the poet and the
speaker.
Why hadn't Milton pressed on
this possible distinction
earlier?
The answer to the question,
I think, gets at the very heart
of the meaning of this elegy.
I think the answer may involve
the possibility that at the
beginning of the poem,
there simply wasn't a clear
distinction between the poet and
the speaker.
It's as if the distinction
between John Milton and the
speaker of "Lycidas"
wasn't really operative.
There wasn't an uncouth swain
at the beginning.You'll
remember that I mentioned
several minutes ago that Milton
appears -- literary historians,
I think, have rightly seen the
Milton who had written "Lycidas"
as a different figure than the
poet before having written
"Lycidas."
Milton seems to have
accomplished something in
writing "Lycidas," almost
as if he accomplishes it over
the course of this very poem;
and one of the things that he's
accomplished is his ability to
see himself as someone who has
accomplished something.
He's just written this poem.
And instead of this continual
anticipation of writing
something great,
Milton's able to look back and
find closure in something
already written.
At the very end of the poem,
the uncouth swain "rose,
and twitch't his Mantle blue:
/ tomorrow to fresh Woods and
Pastures new."
You get an image of Milton here
twitching his blue mantle,
his cape over his shoulder,
and dusting his hands and
letting us know that that's
over.
He's finished.
He has completed this lyric
poem.
He's finished with his pastoral.
Perhaps, even,
he has completed the youthful
phase of his literary
career.Now we began
"Lycidas" with an image
of a poet who could only write
this poem -- this is what we
were told -- with forced fingers
rude.
This was an act of compulsion,
and the poet had to be forced
to press this lyric out of
himself.
By the end of the poem we have
progressed from the image of
"forc'd fingers rude" -- this is
an argument that's been made
brilliantly by the critic Peter
Sacks,
the author of a book called
The English Elegy --
we've progressed from the
image of "forc'd fingers rude"
to an image of the poet who
"touch't the tender stops of
various Quills."
The poet's fingers by the end
of "Lycidas" aren't forced or
rude.
They're capable of these
extraordinarily delicate feats
of dexterity,
and that's because the poet has
mastered his touch.
This tactile mastery attests to
something remarkable that's
happened over the course of the
poem,
somewhere below the surface of
the poem, somewhere between the
lines.
Milton has mastered his poetic
touch, perhaps because Milton
himself has been touched.Let
me remind you of that other
intrusive moment in the poem,
the moment when a figure whose
presence we hadn't been aware of
suddenly made -- suddenly
asserted himself.
That was, of course,
Phoebus Apollo,
the great god of the sun and
the god of poetry,
who touched the trembling ears
of the ambitious young Milton
much as he had a couple of
centuries before touched the
ears of the ambitious young
Virgil.
Apollo had touched Milton in a
way that I think we can actually
measure by the end of this poem
because Milton at the conclusion
of "Lycidas" seems to have
assumed the authority of Apollo.
It's as if he's become Apollo
as he himself takes over the
action of touching.
The speaker has internalized
the authority of the god of
poetry.
First he was touched and now he
touches.
He touches the stops of various
quills.
Look at the final lines:
And now the Sun had
stretch't out all the hills,
And now was dropt into the
Western bay;
At last he rose,
and [touched -- no:
At last he rose and]
twitch't his Mantle blue:
Tomorrow to fresh Woods,
and Pastures new.
I'm interested in the temporal
clause "and now."
Milton shows us he's fully
escaped from the repetitiveness
of the "yet once
more"-beginning.
This coda suggests something
like a victory over all of those
worries of unpreparedness as the
worried rhetoric of "not yet
there" gives way to a much more
confident language of present
completion,
the "now."
And now the Sun had
stretch't out all the hills,
And now was dropt into the
Western bay;
At last he rose…
[Laughs]
"At last he rose":
at last who rose?
Who rose?
The sun that was just dropped
into the west or the uncouth
swain?
This is my question to
you.Now we learn,
of course, by the second half
of this line that it has to be
the uncouth swain who rose and
twitched his mantle blue;
but for a moment the "he" in
line 192 seems to be able to
refer to either the poet or the
sun.
Maybe it could refer to either
the poet or the sun throughout
the entire line,
if you think of the mantle blue
as being the actual sky that the
sun is able to twitch over his
shoulder.
I don't know.
It's at this point of a
possible confusion,
at least a momentary,
provisional confusion,
that we know that the poet has
identified with the sun.
He's absorbed the touching
authority of Phoebus Apollo,
the god of the sun.
Milton -- why is that important?
Milton can no longer be chided
or be criticized by Phoebus
because he's become
Phoebus.This momentary
switch-off between the sun and
the poet is just one of this
poem's many substitutions.
You saw earlier Saint Peter
making a related set of
substitutions,
and it was crazy.
Peter was lamenting Edward
King's death,
and he claimed that he would
gladly have spared an entire
slew of corrupt Anglican
priests.
He would gladly have sacrificed
them in order to keep the much
more virtuous and pure Lycidas
-- a gruesome proposal,
but it's a gruesome proposal
that suggests a primitive desire
for a quid pro quo.
It's the same desire for some
kind of sacrificial substitution
that, I think,
is fueling the poem's ending.
The dynamic of the entire poem
is one of sacrifice and
recompense.
Edward King gave his life,
and he's recompensed by his new
status as the genius of the
shore.
But John Milton is also
recompensed and,
by the weird sacrificial logic
that Saint Peter has already
sketched out for us,
you can see a really [laughs]
disturbing way in which Milton
has benefited as well.
It's as if Lycidas has died so
that Milton could live to become
a great poet.
Lycidas' untimely death seems
to enable Milton to master his
own fears of untimeliness.
Lycidas' death -- remember this
is the poem that Milton didn't
want to write,
he was "forc'd" to write it --
Lycidas' death allows the
uncouth swain to grow up and to
move on.
The last eight lines announce
the course of this new poet's
life -- announce the fact that
this poet's course in life is
about to undergo a drastic
change.In fact,
biographically this is what
happens to Milton.
Finally, John Milton leaves his
father's house.
He moves out and he goes on --
and of course,
he's still being supported
quite generously by his father
-- nonetheless,
he goes on an extended tour
through France and Italy.
He manages to discard that
youthful, that uncouth,
affection for chastity that had
been such a part of his
imagination,
and he marries a young woman
named Mary Powell.
Now it's still going to be
another twenty-five years before
Milton writes the great epic,
but Milton will no longer
express the same degree of
anxiety about under-preparation
to write the great epic.
In fact, this is an argument
that's been made a number of
times, and I think there's a lot
of sense to it -- the last eight
lines of "Lycidas" are
written in a very specific line
form: the Italian scheme of the
ottava rima.
It's the ottava rima in
which all of the great Italian
romance epics by poets --
favorite poets of Milton's like
Ariosto and Tasso -- had been
written.
The appearance of this
semi-epic rhyme scheme here at
the end of Milton's poem
suggests his readiness,
and he's ready only here at the
end of "Lycidas" to embark on
the epic project.Okay,
quickly I'm going to ask you to
turn to the very beginning of
"Lycidas," page 120 in the
Hughes.
So "Lycidas" was
published along,
as you know,
with the other poems about
Edward King in 1637,
but Milton himself publishes
the poem a second time in his
own volume of poems that he
publishes in 1645.
It's for this second printing
that Milton adds the headnote
that you see here that now
begins the poem:
"In this Monody the Author
bewails a learned Friend,
unfortunately drown'd in his
Passage from Chester on the
Irish Seas, 1637."
It's interesting that Milton
certainly begins this headnote
with suggesting directly to us
that it's Milton speaking and
not a fictional uncouth swain.
That aside, let me continue:
"…
on the Irish Seas, 1637.
And by occasion foretells the
ruin of our corrupted Clergy,
then in their height."Eight
years after its initial
composition,
Milton looks back at this
elegy, rereads it,
and picks out the Saint Peter
passage on the corrupted clergy
as that specific feature of the
poem worth singling out and
introducing.
Of course, in a lot of ways
this is just good marketing.
Since the poem's initial
appearance, the institution of
episcopacy, or church hierarchy,
has been seriously eroded.
The first English civil war has
already broken out,
setting Puritans like Milton
against the royalists and the
supporters of the state control
of the church,
like the king and like the
king's dread Archbishop of
Canterbury, William Laud.
When Milton writes this little
headnote in 1645,
Archbishop Laud has been
executed.
He's been sacrificed to the
Puritan cause.
And Milton reasonably alerts
his reader to the timeliness of
a lot of the material that would
be covered in this poem.But
this headnote goes a lot further
simply than that:
"And by occasion foretells the
ruin of our corrupted Clergy."
Milton is -- this is outrageous!
He's actually claiming that
this poem had been prophetic,
that "Lycidas" foretold
the ruin of the clergy.
It's possible that Milton's
actually suggesting,
I think, that this poem helped
bring that ruin about.
You know that Milton had been
entertaining this fantasy of
becoming a great biblical
prophet like Isaiah as early as
the Nativity Ode.
He'd seen himself as a
Jeremiah or as an Isaiah,
and there were all those early
gestures of prophecy.
But now he's able to tell us
that he has already become
prophetic.
He throws his high prophetic
talents into the construction of
the Saint Peter speech;
and in 1645,
historical circumstances being
what they were,
he was able to look back at
this passage and actually claim
that it had been a genuinely
prophetic utterance.
He's made good on all of his
promises.Of course,
it's a sleazy move for Milton
to have made,
to claim [laughs]
that he had actually
prophesied, let's say,
the execution of Archbishop
Laud -- but Milton will
capitalize and exploit any
evidence he can possibly find to
assure himself that he is on the
appropriate path to become the
great prophetic poet that he
knows he is entitled to become
and that he has been chosen to
become.
Finally, Milton has revised and
undone the anticipatory logic of
the great career narrative.